dans la vallée de chevreuse 80 personnes
avec un handicap mental vivent et
travaillent à l'arche d'aigrefins créée
en 1980 au sein de cette ancienne ferme
fortifiée les travailleurs handicapés
s'activent à la salle communautaire pour
préparer le marché de noël
nous sommes enfin faire des couronnes de
noël lebon résultat c'est d'être créatif
qui aimait des boul sapin décoré ben
muna magali et les autres sont aiguillés
par les bénévoles
elles sont pour certaines présentent
depuis 10 ans grâce aux six bénévoles
l'atelier peut fonctionner l'arche des
greffons accueille 44 interne et 36
externe
ça fait oublier des deux ans que je sais
juste pas cet établissement et du coup
voilà je suis en stage pendant 16
découvertes dans l'atelier d'artisanat
huit travailleurs viennent chaque jour
de 8 heures à 17 heures pour faire
essentiellement de la couture beaucoup
de produits en développement durable
seront proposées pour le marché de noël
on a des bouillottes
il fonctionne très bien puisqu'elles
sont graines de lin bio et elle soulage
les articulations parfois mieux que les
médicaments un peu fort et là par
exemple en couture on vient de lancer un
protège celle en toile enduite pour ne
plus avoir les fesses ou mouillé quand
on prend son vélo l'hiver l'activité
s'est diversifiée pour que chacun puisse
maintenir son attention
les travailleurs handicapés ont
confectionné des nouveautés pour les
ventes mari adore la couture mais elle a
une autre passion la dorure en train de
doré décale base qui ont séché qui ont
été produites ici au jardin maraîcher en
objets de décoration pour la période de
noël ou pour soutane et chaque personne
selon sa fragilité sa sensibilité oeuvre
pour ce marché de noël leur confection
sont à retrouver samedi 30 novembre et
dimanche 1er décembre de 10h à 18h à
l'arche d'aigrefins